[Music]
in my opinion you'd think Brad Pitt
would want to get that ridiculous Chanel
number 5 ad behind him right act like it
never happened because people think it's
silly and they're making fun of it you'd
think he'd move on no that's not the
case he seems to be going with it look
at this recent interview he did on
Entertainment Tonight handsome in a
leather jacket his beard getting gray
Brad loved playing the hit man brought
in to take down the bad guys this is
just business I mean these are the rules
of the game and everyone knows if you
step out then you know you're gonna get
fired and and and it's not a journey
every journey ends we go on the world
turns when we turn with plans disappear
from your stick holder but wherever I go
there you are
look my fate my fortune five inevitable
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm always worth until he says Chanel
number five it never fits what he's
saying what do you want from me he's
nuts
I just wanted to stare at you for too
long